the Ukrainian seat was empty as Russian
foreign minister Sergey lavrov addressed
the general assembly the Americans left
one seemingly disinterested
representative the veteran Diplomat
defended the [ __ ] referenda underway in
occupied territories in Ukraine and
claimed the U.S was using the war to
pick a fight with Moscow
it is very clear to any unbiased
Observer for the Anglo-Saxons who
completely subjugated Europe Ukraine is
an Expendable material in the fight
against Russia NATO declared that our
country is an immediate threat on their
way to Total Domination and a long-term
threat will be the People's Republic of
China at the same time the collective
West headed by Washington is sending
frightening signals to other countries
saying anyone who disobeys can be next
almost every country addressing the
United Nations has called for an end to
the war and in the Halls here there's
talk of the Turks or the Saudis acting
as a go-between to get both sides
together
but at a lengthy news conference after
his address lavrov claimed Ukraine
wasn't interested in negotiations
what kind of negotiations can even be
considered the last thing that happened
in terms of contacts with the ukrainians
was our consent to their paper on the
principles for a settlement after this
they moved in a completely different
direction
the Russian speech came as people in
Russian occupied parts of Eastern and
Southern Ukraine voted on whether to
join Russia lavrov says the vote is
about self-determination Kiev and its
Western allies says it's a sham and the
results that have foregone conclusion
and when they are announced it's
expected to ratchet up the tension
between Russia and the West even further
Alan Fisher Al Jazeera at the United
Nations in New York